SHORT OF WORLD-CHANGING.
WHEN YOU VISIT THE FACEBOOK
CAMPUS YOU GET THE SENSE THAT
ANYTHING IS POSSIBLE.
>> WE WANT THE CAMP TO US FEEL
LIKE A LITTLE CITY OR VILLAGE.
>> Reporter: AND NOW ZUCKERBERG
WANTS TO MAKE THE ENTIRE WORLD
LIKE THE FACEBOOK CAMPUS IN A
WAY, BY PROVIDING INTERNET
ACCESS TO THE ENTIRE WORLD.
THE IDEA IS CALLED INTERNET.ORG,
ITS TARGET?
THE 5 BILLION PEOPLE AROUND THE
GLOBE WITHOUT ACCESS TO THE NET.
>> HERE WE USE THINGS LIKE
FACEBOOK TO SHARE NEWS AND CATCH
UP WITH OUR FRIENDS BUT THERE,
THEY'RE GOING TO USE IT TO
DECIDE WHAT KIND OF GOVERNMENT
THEY WANT, GET ACCESS TO HEALTH
CARE FOR THE FIRST TIME EVER,
CONNECT WITH FAMILY HUNDREDS OF
MILES AWAY THAT THEY HAVEN'T
SEEN IN DECADES.
GETTING ACCESS TO THE INTERNET
IS A REALLY BIG DEAL.
I THINK WE'RE GOING TO BE ABLE
TO DO IT.
>> Reporter: THE WORD "WE" IS
THE KEY WORD.
THIS ISN'T JUST ABOUT FACEBOOK.
ZUCKERBERG HAS DONE SOMETHING
EXTRAORDINARY TO ACHIEVE THE
EXTRAORDINARY, REACHED OUT TO
THE BIGGEST PLAYERS IN SOCIAL
MEDIA AND MOBILE DATA, AKA HIS
COMPETITORS IN PART, TO WORK
TOGETHER.
HOW DID THOSE CALLS GO?
>> IT PROBABLY VARIES.
BUT IN GENERAL, THESE ARE
COMPANIES THAT WE HAVE DEEP
RELATIONSHIPS WITH AND HAVE
WORKED WITH ON A LOT OF THINGS
FOR A LONG TIME SO THIS KIND OF
CAME OUT OF A LOT OF THE
DISCUSSIONS THAT WE HAD.
>> Reporter: SO A TEAM OF THE
BEST IN THE BUSINESS IS COMING
TOGETHER BUT FOR A TASK THIS
SIZE, YOU NIGHTING FIVE TIMES
THE GLOBAL PRESENCE FACEBOOK HAS
ALREADY, IT'S GOING TO TAKE A
LOT MORE.
WHAT ABOUT THE HOW?
LIKE HOW DO YOU DO THIS?
HOW DEVELOPED IS THE PLAN?
>> YOU KNOW, WE HAVE A PLAN, A
ROUGH PLAN FOR WHAT WE THINK
WE'RE GOING TO NEED TO DO TO
PULL IT OFF, AND OF COURSE THE
PLAN WILL EVOLVE OVER TIME AND
WE'LL GET BETTER IDEAS, BUT IF
YOU LOOK AT THE TRENDS, DATA IS
BECOMING MORE AVAILABLE TO
PEOPLE.
APPS ARE GETTING MORE EFFICIENT
TO RUN.
THERE ARE NEW BUSINESS MODELS TO
HELP MORE PEOPLE GET ONLINE.
IT'S ALSO GOOD FOR FACEBOOK AND
THE OTHER COMPANIES, RIGHT,
BECAUSE MOBILE ACCESS TO THE
INTERNET IS WHERE YOUR BUSINESS
LIES, RIGHT?
>> IF WE WERE JUST FOCUSED ON
MAKING MONEY, THE FIRST BILLION
PEOPLE WE'VE CONNECTED HAVE WAY
MORE MONEY THAN THE REST OF THE
NEXT 6 BILLION COMBINED.
IT'S NOT FAIR BUT IT'S THE WAY
THAT IT IS.
AND WE JUST BELIEVE THAT
EVERYONE DESERVES TO BE
CONNECTED AND ON THE INTERNET SO
WE ARE PUTTING A LOT OF ENERGY
TOWARDS THIS.
>> PEOPLE SEE YOU AS SOMEWHAT OF
A COMEBACK KID RIGHT NOW.
FORGET ABOUT THE KID NOW BUT
IT'S A PHRASE.
YOU TOOK SOME LUMPS AND FOUND A
WAY TO COME BACK.
ARE AWE WARE OF THAT?
DO YOU FEEL THAT IN YOURSELF
THAT, LIKE SOME PEOPLE THOUGHT
IT WASN'T GOING TO HAPPEN, THAT
YOU HAD HAD YOUR RUN BUT LOOK AT
ME NOW?
DO YOU GET A SENSE OF THAT?
>> WE'VE ALWAYS JUST FOCUSED ON
BUILDING SOMETHING GREAT OVER
THE LONG-TERM.
RIGHT, SO EVERYONE AT FACEBOOK I
JUST TELL THEM COME IN AND TRY
TO MAKE THE BIGGEST IMPACT THAT
YOU CAN HAVE AND IF WE KEEP
BUILDING A SERVICE THAT PEOPLE
LOVE AND THAT MORE AND MORE
PEOPLE USE EVERY DAY WHICH WE
SEEM TO BE DOING PRETTY WELL AT,
THEN WE'RE GOING TO BE FINE OVER
TIME AND THAT'S OUR FOCUS AND IN
TERMS OF BUILDING THE COMPANY.
>> Reporter: HARD TO DO WHEN YOU
HIT THE BUMPS IN THE ROAD
THOUGH, RIGHT?
IT'S A GREAT MESSAGE WHEN
EVERYTHING IS OKAY.
>> ESPECIALLY IMPORTANT WHEN YOU
HIT THE BUMPS.
>> WE'RE NOT TRYING TO CONNECT
THE WORLD TO THE INTERNET.
YOU HAVE TO RUN ONE OF THE
BIGGEST COMPANIES AND WHEN YOU
WANT A DISTRACTION FROM THAT
YOU'VE DECIDED TO TAKE ON THE
EASY TASK OF IMMIGRATION POLICY
AND THE UNITED STATES.
WHY ARE YOU WADING INTO THOSE
WATERS?
>> WHEN WE WERE FIRST TALKING
ABOUT DOING THIS A LOT OF PEOPLE
ACTUALLY WERE WORRIED THAT IT
WAS GOING TO BE A PROBLEM FOR
FACEBOOK, AND I JUST DECIDED I
THINK THAT THIS IS TOO IMPORTANT
OF AN ISSUE FOR THE COUNTRY.
THERE ARE 11 MILLION
UNDOCUMENTED PEOPLE WHO CAME
HERE TO WORK HARD AND CONTRIBUTE
TO THE COUNTRY AND I DON'T THINK
IT'S QUITE AS POLARIZED AS
PEOPLE ALWAYS SAY.
>> Reporter: WHAT WOULD BE YOUR
ADVICE TO PEOPLE IN D.C. WHO ARE
TRYING TO BALANCE THESE TWO
ALMOST DIEIAMETRICALLY OPPOSED
POSITIONS, ONE IS IMMIGRATION
POLICY, LET'S BRING IN OUR HUMAN
POTENTIAL AND THE OTHER ONE IS
LET'S FIND A WAY TO GET THEM
OUT.
HOW IF YOU HAD TO ENTER THAT,
THIS IS YOUR NEW TEAM, YOU HAVE
TO MAKE THESE DEMOCRATS AND
REPUBLICANS COME TOGETHER, WHAT
ADVICE DO YOU THINK YOU'D HAVE
THAT'S NOT GOING ON DOWN THERE
NOW?
>> WELL I CAN'T REALLY TELL
ANYONE HOW TO LEGISLATE.
I MEAN THAT'S -- EVERYONE
UNDERSTANDS THIS STUFF WAY
BETTER THAN I DO, SO MY GOAL IN
THIS IS JUST TO TRY TO HELP
SUPPORT FOLKS WHO CARE DEEPLY
ABOUT GETTING THIS DONE, ON BOTH
SIDES, AND HOPEFULLY WE CAN MAKE
A DIFFERENCE.
>> IN TERMS OF THE POLITICS, YOU
THINK IT'S IMPORTANT ENOUGH
WHERE YOU'RE GOING TO DO IT
ANYWAY.
>> I THINK THERE ARE SOME THINGS
IN LIFE THAT IF YOU BELIEVE THAT
IT'S SUCH A BIG PROBLEM, YOU
JUST STICK YOUR NECK OUT AND TRY
TO DO IT, RIGHT, AND I MEAN, A
LOT OF PEOPLE THINK THAT IT'S
GOING TO BE REALLY CHALLENGING
TO CONNECT 5 BILLION PEOPLE,
TOO.
IT IS, BUT I THINK IT'S ONE OF
THE BIGGEST PROBLEMS OF MY
GENERATION TO GET EVERYONE IN
THE WORLD TO HAVE INTERNET
ACCESS AND WHEN SIMILARLY 11
MILLION UNDOCUMENTED PEOPLE,
THAT'S A LOT OF PEOPLE WHOSE
LIVES WE CAN IMPROVE AND MAKE
THE COUNTRY STRONGER.
>> GOOD LUC